all right miss jolie can you tell us how
does it feel
how does it feel to be a spelma mom i'm
so excited angelina jolie is one proud
mama
and like many parents she gets emotional
as she sends her daughter zahara off to
college she's growing up so beautifully
on wednesday the actress moved her
17-year-old into school at spelman
college the university's vp of student
affairs darrell holloman posted this
video of angie with the school's
president dr helene gail the oscar
winner keeps it real about her baby girl
flying the coop all right miss jolie can
you tell us how does it feel i'm gonna
start crying how does it feel to be a
spell my mom started crying yeah she's
holding back the tears for now i heard
tomorrow night's the big day all right
it is it's a bit together it's a big
deal how does it feel to be a spelma mom
i'm so excited and spelman college is
excited to have zahara dr gail tells e.t
quote we are honored that zahara jolie
pitt and her family chose spelman
college and we welcome zahara
enthusiastically into the spelman
sisterhood i feel like my world expands
as their world expands
i learn so much from them and yeah i
love this stage college drop-off comes
just weeks after the mother-daughter duo
celebrated zahara earning a spot at the
university
that's angie breaking into the electric
slide alongside some of zahara's
classmates and alums on instagram the
eternal star shared this photo of zee
with her spelman sisters and wrote in
the caption it's a high honor to have
her little girl attending school there
when your children are your best friends
it's kind of a it's a nice life but this
isn't the first time the mom of six has
sent one of her kiddos off to college i
just sent one off but he was so i'm so
proud of him back in 2019 she dropped
off her eldest son maddox at yonsei
university in south korea i leave today
today's the day
i know
i'm trying not to cross have you stopped
crying yet no
did you have the ugly cry i can't
imagine angelina
but did you have the ugly embarrass your
children ugly cry the amount of times i
turned and waved it was like i do know
it was the one moment in my life i think
i turned around
six times but lucky for angie she's not
quite an empty nester yet she still got
vivienne knox shiloh and pax at home
their dad angie's estranged husband brad
pitt told e.t last week he just hopes
his kids follow their hearts i love them
to find their own way find the things
they're interested in find their own
voice and flourish and now it's time for
zahara to flourish in college good luck
to the new freshman
[Music]